bipartisan backlash to the crisis at our
southern border with lawmakers on both
sides calling for big changes
republican senator lindsey graham and
democratic representative henry cuellar
calling on president biden to bring back
a former obama official to oversee
the problems at the border i've been
very respectful very supportive
of the administration but something has
to change
when it comes to border immigration
we're urging
president button to create a special
position
to bring order to chaos put somebody in
charge whose focus is just on the border
and all the
problems associated with it that would
have uh
credibility in the eyes of congress and
that's jay johnson
former dhs secretary so that comes as
the justice department threatens legal
action
over an order from texas governor greg
abbott that bans non-governmental ground
transportation of migrants who could be
infected with covet okay
jesse um he says let's appoint someone
to oversee the border i thought that's
what the vice president was doing yeah
root causes shannon that's a lot
different than actual
border problems so the media has really
failed to do its job because that's the
only way biden's gonna do anything is if
they hold his feet to the fire
and we had our team research because
they stopped covering the border
they covered the border from about
mid-march to
mid-april do i have that right and just
a month
and something happened at the end that
made him stop covering it we looked into
and this is what it was biden started
hiding the kids
the media was only interested when there
was children to film but once he started
scooting them out
to these private places they couldn't
film the kids so they dropped it
the other thing is he announced the
basque mandate that came off so
everybody went oh that's really exciting
and the chauvin verdict dropped so those
three things made the media just forget
about the border
and to be honest with you and i'm guilty
of this when you're living in new york
as a member of the media
you don't pitch stories to go south
after
about march because it's hot and then it
gets nice up here why is that
because you don't want to get a little
sun greg so they went and got their son
in february and march and then they
don't do that anymore so
they're just not going to cover the
story at this point anymore and that's
terrible because biden's not going to
solve the problem he creates the problem
his donors love it because they get the
cheap labor left wing loves it
but they're really importing covid19 and
that's a real problem
i saw the tucker thing the other day
people are now arming themselves i am
i'm very scared a rancher is either
going to get shot
or a landowner is going to shoot an
illegal trespasser and then it's just
going to refocus everyone's attention on
the border and sadly it's going to take
a homicide
to get people's attention again yeah i
certainly hope not we were talking
during the break too about this morning
i'm reading in the miami herald about
the u.s coast guard going out
and interdicting people who are trying
to come here from cuba we know they're
facing potential death political
persecution and prosecution
um and yet katie what we're told is that
the border is under control
the south um people are going to
continue to come across there in many
ways unfettered and we're turning around
people that we know would
probably have legit asylum claims well
we're turning around people who
were waving american flags so apparently
that's not okay according to the
department of homeland security if you
have covid and you're walking over the
border and you want to get on a bus or a
plane and go anywhere in the country
you get that for free from the federal
government i don't understand how it is
okay
for the government to allow coveted
positive individuals who
broke the law to get into the country to
infect other people at public
establishments not to tell local law
enforcement
that they are there at the same time
from washington d.c americans are having
to go through all this this other stuff
we keep hearing from people like richard
that the unvaccinated are the problem
well what about the unvaccinated illegal
immigrants who are coming over the
border
by the thousands every single week and i
think this letter that uh
lindsey graham and henry cuellar wrote
to the president today
i thought the part about jay johnson
when he says the reason we're picking
him
is a it's not about putting a republican
in charge it's a former dhs official
and also they said it's because he has a
a history of
implementing public health protocols
which minimize risk to
two americans from foreign travelers and
that's what this is about like aren't we
supposed to be
protecting americans from the situation
and so we'll see if they actually go
through with that but
i mean richard does this step on the
administration's messaging about
the president was passionate yesterday
saying please i'm appealing to you let's
get this done let's protect people let's
do this you know everybody has to do
their part
and people have eyes and ears they can
see what's happening at the border and
they hear these cases
it seems to um you know some folks are
going to take him less seriously with
that still going on listen i do think
the president has a problem when it
comes to figuring out how we deal with
the
code of cope with positive people who
are crossing the border and how we
manage that and so i think that
hiring somebody like jay johnson to the
job is not a bad idea he's he's skilled
he's been it he's been in homeland
security he understands the job with
that being said i think we have to have
a larger conversation about how we fix
the problems at the border i had a
chance to i do stories on the border
still i don't know about jesse
but i wrote a story about the border for
forbes and what we found was after
talking to
folks who are seeking asylum who would
qualify just like the cuban migrants who
are coming to this country
right the problem is that we have an
archaic and old system according to the
american immigration law association of
their bar association their new
president eleanor
interviewed and sat down with me and
said you have to understand we are
literally working on 1980s laws
and we have a court that's absolutely
backlogged and a court that is not like
the normal court that you see every day
where the judge is separate from the
prosecutor they all have the same boss
which allows them to mandate quotas
which allows them to slow down and speed
up the process
and so we have no appetite in dc
regardless of who's running the white
house or capitol hill to actually
change the 1980s laws i agree with you
on that and i'm happy to see some
bipartisanship on capitol hill to say
and hopefully the president will hear
that and say listen bipartisanship is
what he came to washington to do listen
to these two members of congress and
figure out how do we actually pass
something that deals with this that
deals with the dreamers and gets it all
solved
uh so greg apparently the cubans need to
go to mexico and then come in that way
exactly that's the larger conversation
we keep having
we've had a larger conversation on this
for so long saying we're having a lo we
need a larger conversation
that's just kicking the can down the
road and i hate using that phrase
richard and i
angry at you for making me use that
phrase
i'm angry you do you use the phrase this
is not about america
right it's it it that's why the media
the media can only deal with left versus
right conflict okay
it's it that's why we're wondering we're
going like why isn't the media covering
this because this is really hurting
america
because that's not their interest their
interest is to create a profit based on
left versus right
you they call so they can call you a
criminal for not wearing a mask
and call you a criminal for not being
vaccinated they could arrest you if you
don't wear a mask
but if you say someone crossing the uh
the border is illegal
ah you're a bigot so there's all this
law breaking going on that could get you
rest but they won't do that but they'll
come after you about a mass
this is what i am very uh uh cynical
about any kind of bipartisanship on this
because the administration could stop
this
today all you have to do is send the
message don't come and then
close the you can literally close the
border
and deal with it seriously but did you
ever notice how easy it is for
things to be turned off and turned on
based on
who's in power it's like twisting a knob
pre-election
you had a lot of anti-fog you had a lot
of blm post-election
where did they go it wasn't like their
needs were met
we don't hear about them anymore we
don't see any footage of it it's the
same thing with the border searches
but no way let me
were not like this pre-election
post-election now they can come in
what i'm saying is when the dems are out
of power there's a threat of violence
nationwide
no open borders kids in cages of course
democrats
come into power the activism stops
because they got what they want and they
open the border because they want people
to come in
so they were actually this stuff is
manipulated
by people in power they could stop this
they could turn the dial but they don't
that's my book greg but
donald trump closed the border with
title 42 in march 2020 march 2020 and
people were crossing the border so i
don't know
well and now this administration this
administration folks crossing the border
well
no no no no that's like saying that well
there were still folks crossing the
border so you can't and it also
it also rained it also rained but it
wasn't a typhoon yeah but you
you're saying that you could type the
numbers listen everybody agrees based on
data from the government that is
nonpartisan that these numbers are the
worst they've been
500 increases yes very long time okay
just hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else